[Musik]
haie lieben heute gibt es mal einen
akteur so freies rezept weil er mich
auch ganz ganz oft gefragt habe ob ich
denn mal 1 kreieren kann
und ich nehme natürlich auch eure
wünsche zu herzen und habe mir jetzt
eine laktosefreie sahnetorte überlegt
bevor ich jetzt aber zum rezept über
gehe nur eine ganz kleine einführung in
das thema laktose und laktose intoleranz
für alle die sich vielleicht jetzt noch
nicht so damit befasst haben fakt ist
aber dass 80 prozent der erwachsenen
weltweit unter einer laktoseintoleranz
leiden
jetzt war kurz zum anfang was bedeutet
überhaupt laktose das ist ein
lateinisches wort und bedeutet ganz
einfach milch zucker milch zucker ist
ein dieser verrät also ein zweifach
zucker wichtig ist damit wie laktose
vertragen können dass der bei uns im
körper gespalten wird wir können das
aber nicht spalten weil wir ein ganz
bestimmtes protein nicht mehr
produzieren nämlich die laktase als kind
ist es total easy wir können laktose
haltige produkte trinken und nichts
passiert weil als kind unter anderem
weil man ja auch muttermilch aufnimmt
kann man laktose produkte eben einfach
verdauen und da ist gar kein problem
aber erwachsener mann wird umso mehr
probleme entstehen und das liegt eben
einfach daran dass die laktase nicht
mehr enthalten ist so das problem ist
dass das auch zu blähungen führt und so
einfach unverträglichkeiten zu unwohl
gefühlt und teilweise auch sogar zum
müdigkeit und daher gibt es eben wie zum
beispiel bei kaufland die caffrey reihe
das sind laktosefreie produkte einfach
aus dem grund weil laktase zugesetzt
wird das heißt es wird im vorfeld schon
gespalten und wir können das ganz
einfach ohne probleme trinken essen oder
auch in torten verarbeiten ihr habt ihr
jetzt im titel schon gesehen und auch im
teamplay wir machen heute natürlich auch
ein rezept nämlich eine laktosefreie
sahnetorte und dafür zeige ich euch
jetzt meinem sitz biskuit der total
locker ist aber auch sehr schnell geht
und zwar habe ich hier zweier wobei die
ganze menge an ganz schreibe ich euch ja
sowieso wie immer hier unten in die
video beschreibung daher gibt erst mal
einer in die rührschüssel lauwarmes
wasser und zucker gerne auch wenn der
extraktion dazugeben und dann circa fünf
minuten lang richtig schön hält
die mich schlagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
anschließend mehl und backpulver
hinzusehen und nur ganz kurz ein ruhen
bis es sich gerade so verbindet jetzt
ist der tag auch schon fertig hier habe
ich eine 20 zentimeter springform mit
backpapier auf dem boden ausgelegt und
da fühle ich jetzt den teig einen
streich den kurz knapp und dann wird er
gebacken bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für 25 minuten
[Musik]
so ich lasse den boden jetzt erstmal
abkühlen aber in der zwischenzeit zeige
ich euch jetzt mal die sahne creme dafür
nehme ich natürlich die laktosefreie
sahne von caffrey und dann müsst ihr
jetzt generell auch bei allen nackte
fremdprodukten nichts anders machen als
die normalen natur so haltigen produkte
also gebe ich das jetzt in meine
rührschüssel schlag das mit seiner fest
zusammen auf und gibt auch schon wann
der extrakt dazu
[Musik]
die saale ist jetzt schön steif
geschlagen wie auch bei ganz normaler
standard schlagsahne und dann nehme ich
mir jetzt circa fünf esslöffel an die
seite die bei euch gleich für die deko
gebe ich noch direkt schon mal einen
spritzbeutel kurz laut das kommt an die
seite und jetzt fahre ich die schweizer
quack zubereitung zusammen mit dem
doppel ram frischkäse butter zucker und
dann habe ich hier noch der fruchtigkeit
halber so ein paar dosen mandarin und
das werde ich jetzt nicht mit der
maschine sondern nur ganz kurz in einer
schüssel mit einem schneebesen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt schnappt ihr euch einen teig
schaber und hebt die sahne unter in zwei
bis drei schritten ganz vorsichtig und
dann ist die creme auch schon fertig
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich meinen bizkit boden
einmal in der hälfte durchgeschnitten
ein teil dient als boden der andere als
decke und den deckel schneide ich auch
schon mal in kleine stücke denn später
ist die creme schon sehr weiß das sieht
jetzt nicht an daran dass natur so frei
sind die zutaten sondern einfach das
quark mit drin ist und dass ich zum
beispiel keine gelatine benutzt habe
daher auf jeden fall quasi den deckel
schon mal durchschneiden ähnlich wie bei
einer käse sahne torte da macht man das
ja auch also daher nicht wundern
jetzt gebe ich einmal ein tortenring
drumherum und führt dann die creme ein
[Musik]
so das habe ich jetzt noch mal schön
glatt verstrichen und am besten gibt er
den deckel jetzt quasi auf einem
kiteboard auf die creme also ich gibt es
quasi einfach oben drüber
[Musik]
man kann man das hier noch so zurecht
zupfen und das passt auf jeden fall auch
nicht passt wird passend gemacht
jawohl perfekt
so die dort jetzt einmal kühlen für
mindestens 4 stunden gerne auch über
nacht damit alles richtig schön sitzt
und festwirt und bitte an der oberfläche
abdecken damit er nicht austrocknet und
nach der schulzeit ganz einfach nach
herzenslust dekorieren ich mag es ganz
klassisch mit dem puderzucker und mit
sahnehäubchen der restlichen seine die
ich mir bei seite gelegt habe so jetzt
möchte ich noch eine frage klären die
sich euch wahrscheinlich stellt falls es
euch aufgefallen ist warum schmecken
laktosefreie produkte immer ein ticken
süßer als normale ist jetzt auch
aufgefallen bei der milch zum beispiel
im café diana und zwar liegt einfach
daran dass den laktosefreien produkten
denen wird ja laktase zugefügt und die
laktase bewegt ja schon in der packung
quasi bevor ihr die kauf dass sich die
laktose zwei spalte dass sich das
zweifach zucker einfach spaltet das was
er eben nicht mehr können durch das
viele proteine und dadurch nimmt man
diese zwei zucker varian einfach viel
stärker war im geschmack das ist der
einzige unterschied also da ist jetzt
nicht mehr zucker oder so drin
und ja ansonsten würde ich sagen macht
die torte unbedingt nach schreibt mir
bei weiteren fragen gerne hier unten ins
kommentarfeld und haben so und ich
genieße jetzt einen laktosefreien san
sebastian cheesecake den habe ich
nämlich auch mit den kaffeeprodukten
gemacht also auch komplett laktosefrei
und ich bin auch gespannt wir werden
wahrscheinlich auf instagram verkosten
also folgt mir auch unbedingt auf
instagram wenn das nicht schon längst
tot schreibt ihr euch hier unten rein
ebenfalls und dann würde ich mal sagen
bis zum nächsten video channels euro und
der hand sein
[Musik]